Instructor: ES6 has
introduced arrow functions which,
in my opinion, they have three
main benefits. First of all,
they are much concise than
regular functions. Second of all,
they have implicit returns,
which allows us to write these
nifty one-liners. Third of
all, it doesn't rebind the value
of this when you use a arrow
function inside of another
function, which is really
helpful for when you're doing
things like click handlers and
whatnot. We're going to take a
look at a whole bunch of
examples as well as, we're going
to be using arrow functions all
over the place in this course.
I've got this names array right
here, and I want to add Bos to
the end of all three of these.
Normally, you'd do something
like this. You'd say "const,
fullnames = names." and you'd
use map. Pass it a regular
function, it's going to pass you
the singular name, and we're
going to return. We're going
to use back text here, which is
our template strings. Don't
worry exactly about what that is,
if you're not sure just yet. We
have a whole chapter on that
coming up. Name and we're going
to tack Bos on to the end,
console log the full names.
What this is going to give me?
It's going to give me Wes Bos,
Kate Bos, Lex Bos in the entire
array. It took this array,
transformed it into whatever it
was plus the word "Bos" on the
end. That makes sense to me,
but this isn't an arrow function,
so let's take a look at how we
could rewrite that. I'm going to
leave that one up, just so we
can visualize. I'm going to
say fullnames2. The first thing
you do with an arrow function is,
you simply delete the word
function and you put in what's
called a fat arrow. If you've
come from other programming
languages, you might have seen
that before, but in JavaScript
it's the first time we're seeing
a fat arrow. It's an equals sign
with an angle bracket beside it.
That will do exactly the same
thing. We console log it, should
be no surprises there. We get
the exact same thing. That's
the first thing that you can do,
but we can go even further with
it where, if you only have one
parameter...If you've got two
parameters -- that's what these
parenthesis are for -- if you've
got two parameters, you can do
something like that. But if you
only have one, there's no need
to actually have the parenthesis
on it. That's a bit of a
stylistic choice. Some people
say put the parenthesis on
regardless if you have one or
two. In my case, if I have one,
I could do something like this.
That would do the same thing
again with fullnames3. Still
working great. What else
could I do with this? I can use
what's called an implicit return.
What's a explicit return? It's
when you explicitly write the
word "return" for what you are
returning. But a lot of these
call back functions that we
write in JavaScript are just one-
liners, where we just return
something immediately in one
line. We don't need a whole
bunch of lines. Why do we
have to do this return? Well,
what we could do is rename that
fullnames4, is delete the return,
put it up on all of one line,
and then delete your curly
brackets. When you delete
your curly brackets, it's going
to be an implicit return, which
means we do not need to specify
that we are returning name Bos.
It will just assume that we're
doing so. This should give us
the exact same thing. There we
go. Then finally, if you
have no arguments at all -- in
this case obviously we need an
argument -- but if no arguments
at all, you need to pass some
empty parenthesis there. Then
you don't have a name in this
case. Maybe we'll just say Cool
Bos, and they'll all be Cool Bos
at the end. Oops, we already
used that variable here. That's
a little bit of a lesson.
Fullnames4 has already been
declared, because I used it
right here. You can't re-declare
a variable when you are using
const, I should rename that to 5
and make that 5. Another
thing we need to know about
arrow functions, at least right
now, they may change this in
future versions of JavaScript,
is that arrow functions are
always anonymous functions. What
is an anonymous function? An
anonymous function...or maybe
let's talk about, what's a name
function? A name function is
when you say something like this,
function say my name, and you
take in a name, then you alert,
or console log, or return, or
whatever it is. You say hello,
and you pop the person's name
right in there. That's a name
function. The benefit to
using a name function is that if
you have a stack trace, which
means if you have an error and
you want to figure out, where
did this go wrong, sometimes a
line number as to where it
happened isn't very helpful. You
need to know actually the name
of the function that it got
called in. If you use an
arrow function, you cannot name
them. We take a look at all of
our arrow functions here. None
of these have a name. This
doesn't have a name. That's not
even an arrow function. This
doesn't have a name. None of
them have a name. You can,
however, put them in a variable.
If I were to say something like
const, say my name = this looks
a little bit weird, and
sometimes people get a little
bit a freaked out by this. We
could say alert. We're going to
pass it. A name. We're going to
alert, hello, and pop someone's
name in there. Now I should able
to go like this, say my name.
Pass it Wes. If you can spell
your own name that would be
great. There we go, hello Wes,
when you refresh the actual name.
That is actually a function
declaration there. The thing we
need to know about that is it is
an anonymous function and it
will not give us very good stack
traces. However, if you're not
too concerned with that, then
you can absolutely go ahead. Of
course you could put these on
multiple lines as well.